he's a PhD candidate in architecture
history of theory at Columbia University
he's taught in architecture since 1991
throughout the Americas before moving to
New York for his doctoral work he was
the director of the Clemson University
architecture center in Barcelona Spain
and his the title of his talk is Diego
versus Phillip Mama's 1933 architecture
room controversy first of all thank you
for Clara for inviting me to present
this research and for all of you to your
brave than nine o'clock presentation
in 1932 the Museum of Modern Art here in
New York presented exhibition 15 modern
architecture international exhibition
this is a very well-known exhibition to
us in in architecture it set and fixed
the image of what modern architecture
should look like or should be for the
interwar period if not also for later
this exhibition also propelled by Henry
Rushel Hitchcock's and philip johnson's
well-known international style
architecture since 1920 to book
constructed a universal image of
modernity under the guise of style of a
stylistic unity that constructed
consistency for modern architecture and
33 points first was volumes the
construction of volumes as opposed to
mass second was the principle of
regularity as opposed to symmetry and
third and perhaps most know the most
important and I quote the dependence on
entry on the intrinsic elegance of
materials technical perfection and fine
proportions are supposed to apply
ornament this stylistic consistency
created to rate defined two very
important characteristics for modern
architecture first it established a
negation of any other form of modernity
meaning Art Deco streamlining etc which
was then termed as modernistic and not
modern and second it'll establish a
clear distance from the radical
functionalism quote the utility and
nothing more theory of design that
characterized the early development of
the international style this narrative
was constructed through international an
international assembly of architectural
objects which were composed of European
mainly European examples that set the
correct standards of modern
architectural values and
include examples from the United States
and Japan Latin America was not present
in this exhibition what I bring to you
is that before the 1932 architecture
exhibition moma presented another vision
of the modern with exhibition 14 the
u.s. aveda a solo show that grounded the
modern on mexico mural ism this modern
this modernity was grounded on a
narrative arc that celebrates social
confrontation and revolutionary ideals
all under the banner of a national
expression the Vettes modernity was
built with realists figurations
demolished the podium through a
performative technique fresco painting a
production that exemplified the public
nature of art and revealed at the time
of the exhibition the limits of
technical reproducibility Rivera such
was the importance of the performative
nature of Rivera's work of mural ism
that as stated here Rivera and I quote
the museum was brought to new york to
perform some frescoes for us after
exhibition 15 modern architecture the
Museum of Modern Art then we elaborated
Rivera's understanding over the
preposition of a modernity through mural
ISM by presenting murals by American
painters and photographers this is a
list of painters selected by Rivera
himself and but actually then included
the elaboration of murals through
photographic reproductions it could be
arguing that this that this is simply a
matter of institutional topology a
matter of the department of architecture
and painting versus the department of
architecture and presenting different
views of what the modern is I do
recognize this except that exhibition 14
in extreme
16 that bracket modern architecture
cross disciplinary boundaries and make
clear claims into the architectural
reaume and through this this they
reshaped the geography of the
International style ring scribing the
universality of the universe of the
International style with the
transnational character the tension
between the tension between the
universal condition of the international
style and it transnational modernity
this I would argue centering difference
at the core of the modern was brought to
light in a very small exhibition color
reproductions of Mexican frescoes by
Diego Rivera a medication that is now
completely forgotten because of the RCA
mural fiasco if you will where an
exhibition where Philip Johnson curator
one of the curators of the modern
architecture show india with aveda are
brought together to inhabit what it was
MoMA's first architecture room go back
my argument is that this is perhaps one
of the earliest presentations of a
transnational construction of interior
modernity and that the presence of
Rivera Rivera produces a contested space
within the modern interior this small go
back the small room affects the
recontextualization of mural ism from
exterior to interior from public to
private it sees the makeover of the
architectonic wall into a panel and from
the panel into reproductions its
subjects it's reduce the narrative of
social conflict and silences the cries
for political action of mural ism in all
it makes mural ism inhabit the
progressive bujha modern interior but if
if if it does this this exhibition it
also dissenters the main narratives of
modern architecture by forcing a
dangerous coalition that promotes
misunderstanding
in alternative readings domination as
performed by Johnson is in constant
stage of action where the institutional
consciousness at MoMA cannot lean on a
naturalized ideology challenge from
every corner and from every quarter even
from the museum itself Johnson flash
MoMA has to work for at every moment in
every image the seamless universality
that he constructed through the
International style comes undone the
idea of transnationalism is used usually
to disarm or go beyond the idea of the
nation Oh like you propose that here the
idea of transnational as a contested
modernity that actually disarms the idea
of the international now very quickly
because we tend to forget these images
to bring the otha veteran to mec to New
York in the 1930s is a quite dangerous
proposition one wonders why the Museum
of Modern Art headed by a particularly
here in New York it would actually
venture to post that the social social
conflicts we're in order of the day
unions unions in syndicates we're
mobilizing in New York has been riots
since the 1930s early 31 to 35 in New
York artists architects are you are
mobilizing the union statistics are
mobilizing racial tensions are quite
high this is not only in the in New York
but also across the United States were
militant Negroes and I quote in the New
York Times allied with the Communist
Party become associated in extremist
politics oh this is of course it's
crisscrossed with issues of racism this
is a letter by an inner bruceville of
1936 against lynching the radicalness of
basically the political sphere and this
moment as we all now is have been quite
radicalized not
only in the United States but also we
tend to forget this in New York also
here in New York as we can example of
the parades of the German American Bund
and 1936 in New York or this very
unknown moment of this was called the
Harlem Hitler also which was instigator
of the 1934 riots in New York in Harlem
that paints the picture Mexico also
conjures a particular imagery the fear
of the spread of revolution through
Mexico as a platform of the Soviet
revolt is imminent and quite clear in
fact one of the organizers I organizers
of the Nevada show Francis Flynn pain
describes Rivera and a quote as the most
powerful read in Latin America so to
bring dia de vida to New York Rivera
knees and make over one of the key
images of transformations I would argue
is that of the revolutionary figure
portrayed here in the cartoon of a 1916
where Uncle Sam is actually performing
the cleansing operations that has
performed already in the in the
Caribbean and in the Philippines
Philippines because of the revolutionary
upheaval of the 1910 mexican revolution
um that image of pacification which is
actually brought here in in 1916 as an
image that's actually continued I would
argue through the makeover that Rivera
suffers first through his art in 1926
but through general descriptions by
interesting Evans who's actually with
person in charge of actually promoting
this transformation of Rivera of
Rivera's work and which finalizes over
arguing and in her book the very famous
freshness of their Rivera where we have
the Edward Watson's portrait of the
Rivera as a calm introspective
revolutionary the transformation is
finalized by Mama's official portrait of
the 1931 show here we have the
us of the revolutionary hat but also
compared to other figures other forms of
representation where rivers always
portrayed as working on scaffolding he's
here portrayed as a solitary figure
quietly sitting holding a brush in
delicate posting fashion indicating a
retreat from the real not traditional
painting of our end of the artist as a
solitary genius the fact that Rivera's
alone when fresco painting was a
collective endeavor has he chosen his
own self representations here in the
ministry murals in Mexico City
intensifies this retreat from the
collective to the individual from the
public to the private by confining River
to the studio he is confined to the
interior world of art which has the
museum as its showcase place the loss of
the architectural dimension one has to
remember that the frescoes performed by
Rivera were actually citations of the
frescoes in Mexico in actual
architectural settings this loss of the
architectural dimension reveals yet
another of the great operations of the
net 1931 show executed basically the
cancellation of the architectural site
of muir ilysm Mexican muralist created a
problem from the museum of modern art
because it was housed in non modern at
least elliptically buildings this was
one is great detract detractions Mexican
muralist make offer a new society but it
does through in traditionally looking
buildings here at the Ministry of
Education where Jose Vasconcelos had a
very heavy hand on the extension of an
original colonial building into this new
wing which is part of the Mesa where the
freeway def lesbos are located the
solution wasn't to hide and under play
the architectural sites and to celebrate
Independence of the murals through
movable panels this separation from the
architectural wall opens a new
experimental possibilities the
celebrations of the actual mobility of
mural paintings is highly surprised by
moma itself but also intensifies their
decorative aspect it also this
articulates the relationship between
space and pictorial narrative if we can
turn for a second to Joseph Orban's 1930
and useful for Social Research one can
even visit even today I'll do this
because it's also here in New York it's
murals here at the Benton mural from the
nineteen thirty but also here very
important and if horrid picture the
otoscope paintings were painted which
inhabited originally what was the
communal dining room so there's a way of
the architect of the imagery and the
architectonics of the space that isn't
rates fundamental to the relationship
between mural ism and architecture the
conversion two panels that MoMA
promulgated will be sent a new twist
perhaps in the revolutionary slogans in
Mexico that cry precisely erase the
walls when the period i was actually
painting in mexico urban's new school
also help us to focus a little bit in
the argument that Philip Johnson is
trying to deploy through modern
architecture he prices the use of color
in Bourbons interiors yet however he's
completely silent of any of the mural
any of the murals by either certainly by
Orosco or by benton in the building
johnson attends to define the studies of
diction of modern architecture in
nineteen in our in through strict
comparison with the Bauhaus and the
influences in Europe where pure
abstraction is used to actually deploy
the values of modernity now Johnson
attempts to define its stylistic vision
of
architecture in 1931 the year before
motley modern architecture show there
was no that's a rejected architects show
which open which open as a reaction to
the architecture and allies are like art
exposition also in 1931 at the grand
center of galleries here in New York the
problem with this show which was for
Johnson that it created a quote chaotic
plurality didn't it invoked just about
every possible modern or modern of
modernistic style who has and worst of
all actually this show had it had indeed
na yet again representations of do a bit
of murals in the Mexican exhibit this is
the controversy but nonetheless the
architecture room I'll go quickly this
this the the architecture room is a
branch LOL of Albert Alfred bar where he
actually then promotes the the union of
modern architecture and leave me the
Moroi productions of the earth aveda
into a international modernity the
exhibition is a execution of folios a
black-and-white and color but the
important thing is this is celebrated
because new German technology is able to
actually cross the barrier the barrier
of color reproduction and thus these
reproductions are Hale as a
technological advancement the
underscoring of technology / subject
matter which accomplished and
accomplishes the detailed description
everywhere everywhere color palette
palette abandons the social character of
reverse work and instructions fully
within capitalist consumption reverse
production to inhabit a modern interior
but Johnson deploys every possible means
to actually then negate the modernity of
rivera's in a modern interior go quick
if one can argue this in turn it one
could argue that there's a complete
special deployment of the furniture to
block in the presentation of the MU
in Moose mystic form is not as a modern
interior which was actually the goal of
the architecture of the architecture
room it is certainly very clear in the
series of memos that Johnson creates for
press releases were in the very end of
the very last memo he stays also
exhibited are the reproductions of
Mexican frescoes by Jerry Rivera my
point is by understand underscoring the
origin that is Mexican national and
racial Johnson mobilizes the idea of the
nation precisely to start to stress the
unmodded condition of Rivera's work
actually locates modernity somewhere
else not only art but in Mexico because
the originals of these reproductions are
in Mexico and not in the United States
he also eliminates the whole condition
of color which is precisely the
celebration of the technical nation of
Rivera's work a real Rivera's
reproduction there's a whole argument
against this but it's interesting and
just basically finalize this to cleanse
the palate Johnson yet deploys another
version of the Ark of the architecture
room this time connected to the objects
19 Thunder and today which Wesley
precursor to a very famous which I
forgot all reading the minor objects
show the industrial objects show where
he goes so far as not us to produce yet
another version of the interior show
just for the press in which he cancels
if the original architecture
architecture whom was fault it was
constructed through a French
construction of a mobile area this is
decidedly German in origin but it's also
in eco I decided management of any
representation of color in fact he stays
very clearly that the that the objects
should be pure wife should be Clara as
clear as possible simply an uncolored to
ended up the architecture room create a
hybrid space as in cretak modernity
subverting the factual universality of
Eire eccentric modernity
the architecture room created believe a
site for and of contestation it exposed
the idea of modernity in culture as I as
something constructed as a unique as an
uninvited guest in the modern interior
we were at the natural Isis European
international modernity and fortresses
narrator for the Johnson to leave leave
trails expose his tactics and strategies
and reveal his choices such as such as
alternative and not as truth thank you
very much after the presentations will
have the panel come up and for comments
and discussion the next presentation is
by Hannah Gomez transposing imposing
erasing the making of revolutionary
Caracas in the Bolivarian Republic of
Venezuela honea gomez is architect and
urban designer she's the president
founder of the Caracas base foundation
centro de la ciudad and fundacin de la
memoria rahbani she's author of the
forthcoming book el cerrito Theo pontes
masterpiece in Caracas and of numerous
articles and lectures on subjects
dealing with architecture and urban
culture
okay first I would like to thank the
school and professor Clara Clara to
invite me here I'm very glad to be back
in school i'm going to read very fast in
order to because it's a rather large so
starting it goes without saying the city
is a great communicational media and
it's dip fabrica reading the messages of
Villette works everything endless
generations of citizens same to express
through time from there's some emerges
it's divine palimpsest its trace of
identity therefore the importance on
every single urban layer in caracas
regrettably important historical layers
where array is along the centuries
notwithstanding the lagoons caracas at
the end of the 20th century managed to
end up with a very strong image and
image emerging from all its previous
horizons from a genius lachchi anchored
in the geographical qualities and the
whiteness of the sunlight and from the
architectural works of a highly
productive modern era thus caracas
arrives to the turn of the century we
are very defined urban profile and it
what exactly then in nineteen ninety
eight when ruger chavez was elected
president of the country and began what
is known as a fifth republic that is to
say the poly born revolution of
venezuela here we would like to discuss
how a mother in latin american capital
city like caracas behaves at the event
of facing for more than a decade a
radical change in the national political
system what happened when it had
unexpectedly to confront all of a sudden
a revolution it has been said that for
for the break of history with history so
here too all revolutions to take place
it is crucial to start on you it is
demanded to break with the traditional
expressions of the city disrupt its
languages teardown its icons change its
codes substituted servant heroes ray
baptized all things known at the
beginning everyone expected that the
Chavez administration would embrace the
pre-revolutionary in city forks and
traditions leaving denim touch to start
villainous on its own new socialist or
interventions as would do all the
previous Venezuelan government and any
democratic government in the world but
he did exactly the opposite we're going
to present some examples of what has
happened in the Caracas urban fabric
during the now 11 year old olive oil
solution and discuss the different
imposition transpositions and the new
kinds of erasings again within its urban
tree on the other bill Lumia Swiss
writer Robert walser said once the color
white for instance smiles and how
brightly smiles the city of Caracas when
his hit by the sunlight why this
expression of the Capitals local color
climbing the slow coming up from the
Caribbean Sea we are more than half half
a mile closer to the standeth in the Big
Valley the light already white at the
coastline becomes a spherical diffuse
and blinding a city built such a match
in time sometimes sat silently Caracas
was never characterized as we're many
other cities in the rest of the country
or in the region particularly Maracaibo
Venezuela second city for being tropical
it colorful light in the Lehigh Valley
is a strikingly white the Sun immutable
Vedas erode on the landscape with this
extended warm arrow like an emotion of
grace white midday Caracas the circles
were set to to make it to mention the
tower of the cathedral Caracas mmm the
Caracas architectures of all epochs
starting from the White Tower of the
carcasses cathedral at their first
contact with the outside I've always
been irretrievably dissolve in the air
performing an optical metamorphosis
within the channel no fear strong color
so typical of the popular architecture
of Venezuela and sorry although they are
not generally the case I also found a
capital inner it inevitably washed out
first neutralized by the light and then
by the rain the most vivid colors of
colors white and and blur on today
practically disappear there is nothing
to do about it Caracas architectures
once built plunged our dissolve and
covered right away by a transparent the
splendor that annoys them too much light
dazzles and blinds
turning off the most sumptuous of polar
Pollock ramiz things from the summer
things from the Sun who apt Isis things
differently in every place on place on
earth as if someone has a tested one day
why you are into white you will turn the
seed returns in emitted inevitably to
its natural color over time that is why
we say the Caracas another time of Sue
that lose another kind of white city of
tropic and of Caribbean another kind of
ville lumire highlights valet are
flushed by the continued hey see light
city of the limestone architecture this
is the basis of what he wanted to call
remember and get the Caracas fury of
color and a city lab early produced for
centuries must be said once again is the
greatest of all work of art Caracas is
not mark I neither it is willemstad nor
ketone or San Juan nor katakana it is
neither read nor orange green blue
indigo or violet it has its own or color
psychology it is in a servant memory
stretched on a certain form of hot
beauty like that of a white near
Hispanic cathedral tower severe elegant
calcareous unique a real art in which
the absence of color is not an option of
color or at least it was so until
nineteen ninety-eight to impose from the
Latin impunity of in on and pony to put
to attribute falsely sour solderless it
is the image of Caracas has been the
subject of many different manipulations
along its history um something that is
not an exclusive practice of the present
although in the last decade it has
reached levels never before seen the
testament testing one is that either
baller or support the moment that is
they are imposed transpose will race
within the little concert for historical
reality or for the urban memory let's
begin to review some reason or burning
positions in the middle of the last
century for example the main monuments
of the city world painted uniform Ellen
White agreeing with the colors of the
party of government of a time following
the recommendation of a cultural advisor
to this extreme whiteness follows as a
react
propaganda both political the carnival
of colours imposed to the city blue
Caracas historic center to during the
current administration allegedly trying
to give back to the capital city a
popular appearance which as we have not
seen before he has never had the same
thing happens with imposition person
reason of radical changes in the urban
domain clutter the urban spaces in the
capital in the whole country are being
now constantly renamed this always on
with the same objective to creep resent
falsely as new what already exists
already existed at the make believe that
is a new governmental work the
instability of the nomenclature instead
of being yielding locally with the
passage of time and increase of the
historical conscience of the people has
given a step now to a new phase where
changes are being made with a fracking
prudence impotence and which might be
even labeled as nomenklatura Charaka
says in the shabbos times as well said
joseph brodsky about st. Petersburg is
also a reverb tile city parks plazas
Avenue some monuments unexpected it down
one more to win the Fleming signboards
of names that the community didn't know
or approved name said now for sleep
celebrate generally the indigenous
revolutionary or independent Wars
independence work pass in damage of the
city's colonial or mother passed for
instance where are you a platinum for
Avila kuttawa for Columbus parque del
Oeste for park LEP mira parkas casa moda
for parque el calvario nevertheless
invariably in spite of these huge
expenses in new billboards and letters
of all kind made by the Bolivarian
government people keep calling community
places like they did before a little
like what happened in leningrad leader
in the russian revolution the memory of
the calcaneus also turn it to a kind of
resistance of our offer or of urban
subversion and the old caracas in spy
stuttering positions keeps living in its
people with young time and political
changes similar things happened with the
restoration undertaken since 2003 we
will start reviewing that very fast like
a big cultural revolution
the affected by the official is alcalde
a caracas and by its heritage office
pune patrimonio they may monuments of
historic centre both colonial and modern
have been no repeated in bright colors
the city unexpectedly has been trapped
in a blind epidemic passion in a
populist architectural carnival that
threatens all its monuments nobody can
deny degree degree the great need of
restoration of the whole center of the
city for years in the state of
abandonment and practical ruin but using
it as an excuse to build a gigantic
billboard for the revolution has been
one hand a lost opportunity and on the
other a factor of cultural less
information for the population this is
therefore a painted revolution that
believes thoroughly that's what Santa
said Tom Wolfe in the painted word not
seeing is believing but believing is
seeing this phrase immediately came out
to our mind when we'll listen to visit
public declarations of a member of a
member of the sect Oriole office in
charge of the remodeling of the vintage
resonator neighborhood when he assured
after having changed the original
Pollock ramiz of the famous modern
nineteen fifty thousand complex that is
the original color of the facades of
Carol so will be genuine as
architectural project or when some years
ago the blocks of residential complex
were all Payton in orange and it was
also said at the moment that this was
your original appearance of the
buildings built in the 1940s you were in
the government of Hungary nalang kita
both historically false information that
is to say what was why well now it's
orange although it was never arranged
before when was base is not yellow and
what was once a polychromy now it's red
and so forth em ok I will skip some of
this there are 29 some of the most
famous cases a cadre of Carmelita the
old house of the Council of tow bar that
was since always depicted baked all
beige tones the church of San Francisco
traditionally of white color this
important church for example is second
most important of karaka following the
cathedral it was modified in 1873 by the
architect way north america to build a
new facade project that would harmonize
with that of the university building
play where next with my man Ricky simply
said as a good 19th century or a cadet I
know who
state imitates tone in colac park bar in
caracas like in Vienna Paris at the turn
of the 10th century the freezes were
sublime surfaces full of metaphorical
will walls wanted to be an autonomous
autonomous of any constructive logic and
as embroidered surfaces aimed to be
applied to the architectural panels
decorated by the architects and the I
white walls of the skeena San Francisco
simulated authentic ashlar pilasters and
corn is made of stone and remote eyes by
the kuru kuru enough she ducked off our
land because of these the string
renovation executed in 2004 erasing the
trace of the false colors and painting
the shirt in grey and yellow and the
southern facade of the parochial kudiye
in red that looks directed from a vulgar
catalog of painting for exteriors you
nothing that but the conceptual denial
of the 1870s trees project and
antithesis of the temple superb and
austere interiors a polemic
transformation of the images of these
two important landmark of the Caracas
historic center the impact over the
public opinion was so big that the
program instead of being rectified
receiver stronger support from Dell
Chaldea to continue in the same line
from the non swallow the facades of the
Palazzo alahakoon hermes and of the old
palacio de la posicin both before in
white and fair grey and a perfectly
tuned with the recently padded tones of
the continuous church of san francisco
the church ave sagrado corazon dejesus
once in a cream color and now a sky blue
the pantheon nacional originally beige
and sienna and now in pink on green they
consider municipal de caracas originally
else in a queen tone and repeating in
gray and in a strong canary yellow the
public polemic reappear in 2006 mapunda
patrimonio finished as we mentioned
before the restoration process of
ancillary complex like in free to a vast
urban renewal the introduce new house in
return neighborhood in the center of the
city after many years of decay heavy
modification practice to the great
majority of the apartments on a very bad
maintenance from the
undertook an ambitious restoration
project lamentably after restoration
candy well known change of color of the
block passes modify modify and totally
the perception of the urban space with a
general public rejection of this action
every when turned to the architects
daughter Paulina Villanueva who publicly
declared that the color that her fire
reply to the building was originally a
tour at insulting similar to dialect of
an eggshell but her voice wasn't heard
and the buildings were covered in at
anchoring light tone so on after with
renovated strains the changes continued
at theatre national or energy invasion
cream was paid in with a strike in brick
color that plus was is punched besides
the old glass and iron marquee or it's a
main entrance hasn't been put back in
place meanwhile three of the main
architectural monuments of the most
important 19th century part of Caracas
the park el calvario that is to say the
artillery will assume the tunnel you see
the changes the tunnel over calvario and
the chapel of Lourdes have left behind
the snowy shades that made them was
detached as sculptures i miss the green
forest of a calvario hill to become now
the first polychromos the second covered
absurdly like you and the third orange
according to the only lateral decisions
taken by from the battery manos
restoration team decisions that a
technical school of communal artisans
quickly trained by al-qaeda and the
neighboring communities rush to execute
racing here also by the way many of the
original balls are architectural
detailing this term forming fanaticism
and the desire to impose a new image
ended up in the going bigger in going
beyond the surfaces of the patrimonial
structure to reach a close by urban
fabric after a conclusion of the new
nursery calicut restoration where the
numerous bullring was paid in with the
strong primary jealous and red colors
already political conscious because they
are the colors of the actual
government's party
immediately I kalia Caracas to whom must
have exceeded a good reserve of jell-o
Peyton from the last restorations in the
surroundings started to paint the same
mustard yellow on buildings of all
epochs covering with a repetitive Monica
me what before was a genuine expression
of the architectural local languages to
end this list we still have to mention
what happened to the modern housing
complex of the 23 Janero when an y ou
1950s as a paradigm of modernity the
success of this popular housing units
were converted into big abstract murals
basic color plain compositions
commissioned to artists like Myrtle
Manor in victorville later who also
collaborated with en nueva in the sea la
universidad de caracas in spite of the
area's general decay the composition
lasting until now in January 2010 a
great deal of the facade of the blocks
were changed to play red and white
combinations according to the testimony
of writer audrianna region where the
architects granddaughter this Roja
rojito is the emblematic color of the
Revolutionary Government my souvenirs
a23 scenario facades have never been of
a single color but always covered with
polychrome ease this was their charm
with archives of indecision Villanueva
we founded some photos of the Vancouver
area lady from when they went into the
narrow open and there was the red but
although along with the blue the green
the orange the grain on the counter now
the vibration brought by the game of
color of the artists works is no longer
there sometime something by distance of
distant of the spirit of Ian wellas
other knitting regarding on these cases
of repeated imposition stoned by Del
caldiero Caracas DT to dobut Ramona
cultural the maximum heritage authority
of the country still keep silence
transpositions to transpose from the
Latin transponder day I think I'm going
just to show you the images because it
is too long to put in a different place
to remove to change place well this part
of the paper was going to show the
transposition of objects important
cultural objects in the city to change
their meaning when the first case is the
case of myra lyon so 1950s culture that
was placed the entrance
northern entrance of the pseudo
universitario de caracas to act as the
the carrier of the Olympic flame next to
the stadium's that was there a totally
original pedestal and its original
location where the architect placed it
what it is I don't know I have time to
read it over no okay so this is the case
of the study was tried to be moved this
is the original statute in decay stayed
before restoration at the moment of
restoration when it broke yes because
it's not stone it's artificial stone
then the government decided to try to
put in a new place so they indigenous
past and the cultural meaning of the
ugliest actor would change being removed
from the university city and be placed
in a more important location in the city
this is the plaza Venezuela and the
second was the plaza los new sales by
the bad the citizens and the people from
Caracas so strongly and defended the
original site that they couldn't move it
but they even built a Podesta in the
plaza del of new sales which now is
demolished of course so there is a clone
statue that is a standing now in the
original side and the original one is
restore waiting endlessly to be put back
in place a second for a case of
transposition we showed last year and at
fitch Coloccini's the museum leander the
part roberto bulimic sparkly later this
is the project that is started to be
built in the lake 9 destroying
absolutely it's natural or you know
design and in spirit and this is the
situation now a construction has stopped
fortunately because of
the park was listed less here in the
watch list 2010 and also because of our
participation here last year in fecha
Colockum but this is the situation and
the seal the hole is open well and
another kind of thing that happened is
that this year's the bicentennial of the
independence war in Venezuela and the
governor wanted to put a monumental
herbalist in the bully Plaza believer
that is only a few meters less than that
of Windows iris but can you imagine the
size and scale of this object in the end
it started construction but constructor
has stopped but the works are open air
like they are now that is a near to the
chancery and old palace of the of the of
the futon home and while erasing spray
is very easy for the images you would
know all the columbuses statutes of the
city have been at or down this is the
1895 columbus statue that was placed and
originally in top of the pavilion of
venezuela in the columbus exposition in
chicago that was a statue than the claim
from the gym dizziness at Nia's to take
this statue away they finally garlic and
this was last week when another hero of
the federal revolution which was placed
on top of the 19th century this place
same happened with the other columbus
monument column one of the colonial
patristic which was also a very
important artist from the 19th century
was its tattoo and that what the
vandalism against it the search is
kidnapped somewhere we don't know where
it is now and this is the actual
situation of the monument
no comments thank you very much and now
have Ingrid Oliva for a presentation is
questioning cultural cultural heritage
preservation in Puerto Rico through the
case of bond say Ingrid is urban
planning PhD candidate at Columbia
University and her current research
focuses on the interface between
preservation planning and disaster
policies and secondary historic cities
of the Caribbean
this is not mine
yes
first of all thanks to Clara and her
team I actually feel like a profit in my
own land since i'm one of the house
students and i'm very grateful for this
opportunity to present my work this is
what i will try to do in the following
two minutes if my speed allows and bear
with me first with the force four slides
which are a bit preparatory to what's
going to come i am trying to address in
this work how important we call cultural
heritage has been has moved forward to a
hybrid self-identification and respect
for local cultural manifestations but
this has embedded pre loss becomes
preservation has been the domain of the
institute of porto de cultura portola
Kenya which is a public entity set up
after the island obtain a common wealth
status in 1952 and although some of the
task of this institution are under the
National Park Service supervision the
relative autonomy and centralized
mandate of the ISA pay I argue it's a
very important power negotiation in a
sphere that is has been conflicted and
still into definition which is the
recognition of a validated island
identity both by people in the island
and abroad butoh Ricans and the Diaspora
and by foreign rulers and also I argue
that this entails a redistribution of
resources and agency the research
questions guiding this presentation are
basically subsume and to the first is
the national scale level of the policy
how did this preservation the of
cultural heritage developed by an island
institution this is the first chunk that
I'm going to cover hopefully the second
part i'm going to cover refers to pawn
say i am asking how does this translate
to a secondary see
see that aim to be the cultural and the
capital at a point of time and that
despite the Klein that happened for the
most part in the 20th century still is
portrayed as a proud unique place that
wants to reclaim this splendor and power
through planning policies and they said
the third question is actually related
to the second which is specifically what
are the vacuums that I foresee in this
case which is an example for cities in
the global south or how municipalities
how second-tier cities try to achieve
autonomy developmental preservation and
actually through planning I have used
the combined methodology of for
quantitative methods and embedded case
study were tory go is my case and the
sub unit of analysis poncy I conducted
archival research for three years in
situ and over line and in that archival
research I have contrasted technical
works such as planning documents
unpublished policy documents medical
records and so on with non-technical
works such as cartoons postcard songs
literary works in in an attempt to
contrast two ways of addressing the same
problem as academics or intellectuals or
policymakers and as the general Llay
citizens or representatives of the lay
citizens might do I also conduct a
direct observation for five months
monthly in pune's mainly in potency and
in someone and I dedicated myself to
observe interactions of groups trying to
be us less perturbing as possible I also
visited cultural venues and so on and
the fourth method that i have used is
visual sociology i am extracting data or
presenting conclusions from images and
also from text in the images my
framework of analysis for both cases
first the national policy and second the
city policy
and three historical time periods that I
think structure life in Puerto Rico to
set it bluntly how it how the Cologne
spanish colonial framework created a set
of assumptions institutions policies and
how that has influenced my topic
subsequently when the u.s. took over
into nineteen eighteen eighteen ninety
eight through nineteen fifty-two in the
state in which first it was military and
second it was under civil sovereignty
and then the third stage that I'm going
to look at is the Commonwealth era from
1952 to 2009 so during the Spanish
colony cultural domination sustain the
conquest and colonization of Puerto Rico
I am very helpful to some of the
presenters who yesterday advance this
discussion because what I'm trying to
summarize here is that the notion of
habitus as defined by Bo do was
established since the beginning of
colonization and in this notion of
habitus there was a social economic
cultural hierarchy based on nation of
origin based on race and ethnicity
gender and religion this notion still
permeates what today is deferred
defended as culture or not I'm going to
return back to this in my case study but
in that hierarchy it was spanish born
citizens who were occupied in the top
and disregarding their fellow citizens
born in the americas and even more so
people of color as you know the extreme
genocide of indigenous peoples took
place and subsequently after that in
slavery of africans took place and this
social hierarchy is still present over
modified in the understanding of culture
which is basically my second argument
this notion of whitening preference for
his span of philly
architecture waist-train culture and so
on gender class religion defined social
hierarchy and also embryonic notions of
local identity when in the 19th century
there were struggles in the island to
become a nation an independent nation
and this influences what upper dora has
called the politics of remember and the
politics are forgetting in nineteen
eighteen ninety eight Americans took
over after the Civil after the
spanish-american war Porto Rico became
Porto Rico and it was an unincorporated
territory that basically meant that the
colonial status was transferred from one
nation to the other nation and in this
new scheme even the local elites who had
discriminated against their own people
we're facing discrimination based on the
usual suspects you know religion race
ethnicity country of origin gender &
language I'm going to stop here on two
postcards which I think are very
representative of that early period of
US military sovereignty postcards that
time are very useful of that time are
very useful because it has a it's a
moment in which both photography and
post mail were reaching massive use so
they are very important as a means of
communication for travelers and also as
historical documents and that you see
the clear contrast in the top image of
white military newcomers resting in a
camp worked in nature has been given way
to some comfort and be flow you start to
see the representation of Puerto Ricans
us natives as deprived in this case it
is a group of very unhappy children
against an exuberant vegetation that are
cast parlous that they lack basic needs
not even stockings you get shoes so this
is going to play out in the following
policies of
century I want to stop now on how
federally promoted at simulation
prompted rejection mechanisms for
example English was became the official
medium of instruction in public schools
and this decision was extremely
unpopular as this cartoon shows actually
Spanish became central later on to
delineate what Puerto Rican ass man
meant as has been argued by several
scholars like dhwani mm beretta in this
case you see Uncle Sam heating a nail
vigorously with a hammer that is called
English language and the nail is called
Americanization but instead of
penetrating the intact pavement the nail
is bending and at the same time Porto
Rico to the left is represented by a
poor and disdaining man who actually has
the face of one of the autonomy fighters
the father future governor of New York's
medine who's actually sitting instead of
a lush background of a wild forest like
in the past postcard or in attained
nature contests like the American camp
in a very develop urban setting you know
doorstep of what you do building in this
period of transition of American take
over there was a very quick development
of a sugar based economy in which
American firms actually challenged the
supremacy of Creoles so in parallel to a
process of cultural assimilation there
is this process of economic invasion
political restructuring and so on and by
the 30s this initial framework of
governance takes a very different shift
because there is a big decline of sugar
sugar reaches sugar reaches a very high
price before and during the Second World
War but after that the prices collapse
so that sends the Puerto Rican economy
into a big crisis
there are also several disasters that
was in the situation so this is a moment
in which rural decay and crisis prompt
pro-independence struggles arm
independent struggles but also they
prompt the notion that the early
colonizer that will lived in the
interior mountains of the area the
island isolated of white heritage and
the Jivaro which is a rural peasant they
both gained strain strength as identity
corner storms in the moment of crisis
and actually that mimics what some of
the 18th century naturalist nationalist
movements in Europe were doing when
forging nation-states urban
intellectuals regardless of partisan
politics politics idealized rural folk
trades pristine nature in local myths
and folklore which some of them were
actually invented traditions the
response to this crisis is the New Deal
officially and I argue that there's also
a response in terms of extreme
repression the New Deal came to Puerto
Rico and it actually set up a
comprehensive planning paradigm that
embodied a technology of domination over
nature and people through this paradigm
the image of the United States was
redirected from a distant and extractive
colonial power to a regulatory state
engage with everyday life concerns if
time of hallux electrification for
example public housing investment public
infrastructure all that took place at
the same time because of the independent
struggles harassment martial law and the
policies such as the gut law took place
the goggle oh I want to stop briefly
it's known as the lame-o Vasa and by
this law it was proper to jail people
for having patriotic manifestations for
hanging the Puerto Rican flag for
example for speaking about independence
there are records of fun people
were jailed for attending Mass because
the priest had a an overt nationalist
tone for them so this lasts for a period
of time but what is evident of it from
this moment is that there's a need to
address patriotic sentiment and cultural
sensibilities through a more inclusive
and tolerant compromise which is
negotiated in the Commonwealth from 1952
onwards a decisive figure takes charge
here with muoz marn and he in this
project there are two aims at the same
time the first is modern economic
development industrialization through
tax cuts through tax exemptions in the
institutional reform tourism and
migration of this we spoke yesterday and
I think that this part of the agenda has
it took place first in Puerto Rico it's
one of those transnationalism that was
announced in Puerto Rico and has been
experienced subsequently in the rest of
the continent and from that strategy
what is very clear is a large project
called Operation bootstraps I'm not
going to stop into that because it's
fairly well known it was short case as a
development policy for other countries
what is also interesting for me and is
less known is that muoz marn had in
mind that there was a need to create an
ontological security as Anthony Giddens
has defined that is to say in a period
of rapid change in stability we need to
hold on to some values that make sense
to our human experience for him this
could take place if developing education
appreciation of the arts and cultural
heritage preservation and this project
that is the result that thinking is
called operation serenity as part of
that project the ISA pay the Institute
I'm going to talk about was developed so
I probably have to skip this but these
are some of the quotes about the windows
Marine explain his thinking and I look
at the words how poor Ekans want to
continue being kind and tranquil you
know serenity they want to take things
nicely and politely in the moment of
modern civilization they do not want to
be upset by modernity another quote is
that as this as Puerto Rico grows in its
cities and its fields it should be the
preservation of what he considers is a
basic good knowledge be one of the first
achievements of urbanization instead of
being one of the first victims so we
have the instituto de cultura puerto
rican as a result of that 1952 when
archaeologists and anthropologists took
place it took over and his first task
was a pretty difficult task to preserve
all someone which was menaced by intense
speculative pressures and it was a very
symbolic step to affirm what is going to
be culture you know how are we going to
intervene intervene to preserve that
that culture but given the pressures of
the lobby the lobby of the owners also
given the goodness I just have two
minutes left jump it's a president Latin
America here you see if you see or
someone then it like seeing on Havana
now this is a announcing how how good it
was to get gentrified although awesome
one and this is I think the conclusion
of this is that official hispana failure
took over in the crisis of modernity
operation bootstrap proved a failure the
Commonwealth status take over again and
the links between identity and culture
come back to public policy into the
media jumping over that reservation
trying to compare here preservation in
the 60s and the 90s how some of the
assumptions of the built environment
that is to be preserved the Spanish
environment is still like the facade and
pulsate well hey if I'm gonna induce
let's see what I can do once there was a
small coastal farming settlement that
rapid in two centuries later became the
main hub of export when sugar and coffee
exports both a boom in the city and in
this quick there was a quick on even
process of development very stark small
elite had a developed part of the city
that wanted to become the capital this
you can see in the bottom in this square
which is one of the King to central
places of the elite and here i'm trying
to show the hierarchy of the streets
stratification of what of this city that
portrays itself as a proud that's the
capital to be and and this is the other
side of puerto rico el fon say that it's
not developed developed in the
memorization of the city this was for
the most part what constitutes poncy but
but it's not reflected in the narratives
put by the local elites in the 19th
century when Americans come ponse loses
power Americans reconfirms on one
foreigners who had start to control the
representations of ponsor instead of the
local elite cradle so they have
representations of the city that are
balanced some our conventional others
are pejorative colonialist and of this
we're going to see briefly these three
postcards in the top one it's announcing
that the city is like the best economic
arena of ponds laid by an American in
the second one you see this archetypical
snapshots of the city in which to the
left the very elitist snob a casino and
the homes a port to the bottom are
contrasted with the very primitive of
statics in which afro Porto Ricans are
used again as the native so this is
another representation of conse by
foreigners so this is what I'm trying to
portray to you
in this crisis of modernity of the 50s
of core goal and the collapse of sugar
officiating airports and so on poncey
becomes a dismal failure as if it had
been bombed so the response is to
struggle for the city to become an
autonomous municipality a whole planning
process is set up by the major starting
with preservation as the emblem of it
although is a much larger process so in
this last part of the 20th century in
the last 20 years there's a change in
preservation going to a more commodified
approach there is a deregulation of
who's involved there are grassroots
initiatives intellectuals the media so
there's a decentralization I argue and a
much complex scheme of governance and
from this holistic idea to compare
autonomy preservation is one of the key
emblems and that this plan and this what
this means vanity did actually change
power relations in the ions after the
law so are the last this is the major of
the city dreaming that poncy on the top
becomes someone so this is again this
idea of you know struggling to have a
stronger place in the international in
the island and my conclusions is that
preservation has recognized rejected
cultural signifiers and has actually
reduced tributed resources which fraser
and harness are you are two basis of
social justice so recognition and
redistribution have taken place i argue
but still they have taken place in ways
are insufficient and that are open to
arguable critiques such as being
inefficient reified non participatory
and so on we can't discuss that in the
break preservation and ponse follows
island when trends but it also creates
pioneering special processes which i
think are useful to study for second
tier
CDs in the global south and the
preservation I think is a special
mechanism which creates a sense of self
identification undermining the
satisfaction of the u.s. rule and the
last argument is that it must engage in
the quest for empowerment related to
recognition autonomy development a final
presentation is Armageddon can I the
resurgence of the barrios has
socio-political territories in the
transnational space of the contemporary
city of Buenos I days he obtained his
PhD at UCLA in 2008 his assistant
professor at the department of geography
and regional studies at the university
of miami his research explores how
intertwined processes of urbanization
and globalization shaped contemporary
social life in the americas with a focus
on the territorial policies and politics
of the redevelopment in globalizing
cities his work engages with critical
urban theory the spatiality of
inequality regional city and
neighborhood planning and the places of
the middle classes in the contemporary
city
okay Thank You Clara for putting this
great event together and for allowing me
to participate in this very interesting
session as a geographer I'd like to
perhaps with my presentation complement
is largely anthropological transnational
imagination that we've been talking
about for the past two days and what I'd
like to achieve in particular in this
presentation is to somehow show how that
what we call the transnational is
largely constituted in the space of
contemporary thence diverse
heterogeneous and complex cities and
while at the same time much what happens
in those dance heterogeneous and
complexities even what we may be
identifying as purely based or localized
politics is also largely constituted by
the transnational either as a reaction
as a form of trying to cope with it as a
form to trying to engage with it in in
more beneficial terms so that's that's
what my presentation will be today and
about that's how I interpret what some
may see as a resurgence of localism in
the city of Buenos Aires that's what i
call the researchers of the various and
throughout this presentation i'm going
to try to show why okay
so the theoretical motivation for this
work is to try to show that that what I
was saying that could be identifying as
purely local such as processes of sub
municipal de centralization or
neighborhood empowerment are not just or
are not only functions of social
movements and their interaction with the
local state with city governments but
they are also the result the product of
multiple extra local processes occurring
at multiple scales and carried out by
various diverse state and social actors
and what is interesting about this is
that in this era of deep urban
globalization unprecedented mobility and
transnational is transnationalism some
local spaces seem to be gaining or
regaining significance as social
political territories territories for
both the regulation of urban affairs as
territories to acquire voice to acquire
political representation in the
processes of decision-making of how
those processes should be guided so the
example that I'm going to be discussing
today it's based in the city of Buenos
Aires the city of 3 million people the
capital of Argentina and I'm looking at
the local list neighborhood movements
that have occurred among the middle
classes of the city particularly in the
period that starts with Argentina
Argentina's Christ god I can't even
pronounce my own country's name right in
English well what started with
Argentina's Christ neoliberal crisis the
crisis that occurred largely because of
the neoliberal policies that Argentina
pushed sued throughout the 1990s a
crisis that erupted in late 2001 and
continued for 23 years till 2003 or so
so um within the social movements that
emerged during this period between 2001
and 2003 I focus on one one that a
social movement that try to pursue the
advancement of one reform that had been
applied earlier and that's the sub
municipal decentralization of the
in two districts or what it was called
what is called local is communist and we
think that social movement I
particularly focus on one territorial
based framework of collective action and
that is the focus that those mobilize
social actors in the program unas
movement placed on the various the
barriers of the city battering span for
those of you who speak Spanish know that
battery simply means neighborhood but in
the city of Buenos Aires this is also an
official geography as a subdivision of
the city into well known places with
names that have supposedly historical
origins and traditions so I'm going to
be looking at how these frameworks least
territorially based framework of
collecting actions the values were
deployed as discursive constructs to
frame issues and to motivate political
mobilization and to try to pursue a
common interest between the diverse
actors mobilized I'm going to finish my
presentation and a relatively negative
now this is Argentina after all the
mutual reach of the reforms i'm going to
say needs to be understood is very
limited we have to understand it the
communist was a relatively failed reform
it's still not applied and what I'd like
to try to interpret it is why has been
such a weak reform or why the social
movement did not succeed in all of its
gold and I'm going to place those your
comments in in to try to explain them by
both the ongoing city national tensions
occurring in the post neoliberal
Argentina and those struggles taking
place beyond the scale of the
neighborhood place and taking place
between the scale of the city and the
scale of the nation and I'm also going
to look at some inherent weaknesses to
this local East framework of the vario
communi in an era of ongoing
transnational ization for the city so
just to start with a little bit of
background and what happened in the
1990s Argentina wasn't of the most
thoroughly reformed capitalist economies
in the world the coalition that was
stablished around the election of
President Amin
99 was able to carry out reforms that
even exceeded the the regional context
Argentina nearly realize even more than
Mexico even more than Chile arguably
during this period and what it's less
known about this well-known process of
neoliberal ization of Argentina is the
how state territoriality was deployed to
both pursue and support these macro
economic reforms and how concurrently
with those well known macroeconomic
interventions such as the convertibility
currency that tie their gin time peso
121 to the dollar how next to those
macroeconomic interventions neoliberal
argentina embarked in what we call a
process of state restructuring in
reshaping every tooling of the
territorial scaffolding of the argentine
state needed to support for long term
such market centric social order the
Argentinian state restructure rescale in
multiple directions on one direction the
Argentine state went up to the
supranational scale Argentina eagerly
joined Mercosur with Brazil or Y and
Paraguay but with very different
motivations from those of Brazil Brazil
was looking to insert itself as a global
player what Argentina was trying to do
is to liberalize its market by joining
Mercosur there was one way of
liberalizing the Argentinian market and
to establish what it's called a
conditioning framework if the market was
open and allow I would import not only
from Brazil and other Mercosur partners
/ from all over the world it was not
because Argentina wanted to do so but it
was because it was stipulation of
Mercosur so this was used as a
conditioning framework for liberalizing
the local economy at the same time
argentina embarked on a thorough process
of sub-national devolution and
administrative the centralization so
many of the educational social health
services formerly provided by the
argentine state where the responsibility
for the services with strands past
a provincial and municipal neighborhood
and provincial and local governments
without the necessary budget and to free
up the budget of the Argentine state
from those obligations so there was that
sub national scale from from talk to a
top-down not just for a from below but
also from the scale to two scales below
it finally there's a form of external
ization of state of previously known as
a state functions what I call the
outside in the Argentine state frees
itself up from its former functions of
being an originator of economic
development a starter of investment
trends and that functions are trans
passed to the outside to transnational
capital so it's no longer the
Argentinian state who is the main
originator of investments and economic
innovation but now that function is
assumed by transnational by
transnational capital and this is seen
clearly in Argentina's primary economic
space metropolitan Buenos Aires and
particularly the city of Buenos Aires
which becomes a preeminent space for
transnational investment and for trans
nationalization a paradigmatic example
of the strains can be found in puerto
madero a case of state-sponsored
redevelopment and make a project that
involves the city building logics of
this neoliberal regime actually a mega
project in which both city government
and the national government of Argentina
were involved the corporation was
created by joint ownership of showing of
inertia joint of joint ownership of both
City and national governments and it was
deployed to redevelop this area it's not
just for to madera those similar
projects take place throughout the city
in what Graciela Sylvestre and Adrian
Gorelick called a policy of fragments
or a isolated site redevelopment project
largely speculative and larger with the
participation of foreign capital that
can be framed within an entrepreneurial
climate of profit seeking as the main
goal for urban planning an example of
the consequences that such form of
partial or side base redevelopment bring
about can be found in the example of the
avast oh area this is an area a center
around what who used to be buenos aires
main wholesale market for fruit and
produce and this is an area that was
redeveloped mainly in terms of the
principal site this what you see in the
picture the the main market facility
this beautiful art deco building which
is now which now hosts a shopping center
and two high-rise towers were built
behind it in the same side this is
largely an upper-middle-class
development targeting that audience that
it was the redevelopment didn't look at
other spaces that were ancillary to this
main structure other smaller deposits
other structures around the market that
were left to decay and they were largely
squatter and occupied and still today
how's a very disadvantaged population so
we see in the elasto area a new text a
position of wealth and poverty as well
as a trans nationalization in cultural
terms this a vast area it's largely
Jewish there's a large Jewish
concentration here in the abasa there's
new immigrant population as well Lord
primarily Peruvian and so we see here as
what is happening throughout the city
how the city becomes more complex more
unequal more hitter
and it house how it starts to bringing
together complex and problematic
juxtapositions of transnational wealth
and metropolitan exclusion this all has
been very well studied there's a very
good book by maria carmen on the elasto
on in spanish is called las trampas de
la cultura I believe salamu she has
written also a great book last year a
global where she discusses puerto madero
a Basto and many other projects that
have taken place near the 1990s in this
policy of fragments propitiated by the
argentine state so this is a rather
familiar story by now by now of what
happened in the 1990s but the story
continues a decade has passed since then
after the Argentine crisis of two
thousand and one that is now being
understood as one of the biggest
failures of Mar concentrix policies in
the world perhaps until the foreclosure
crisis here in the United States the ax
largest neoliberal failure up to date
again much of this has been discussed in
terms of national politics and
macroeconomics but what I'm interested
is the urban implications of this
failure and its reactions what has
happened in terms of Earth of the urban
in this post neoliberal period so what
it's interesting is that during the
height of the protests between 2001 and
2003 we have new political actors taking
up to the street the formerly equus
acquiescent urban middle classes are
seen side-by-side with popular movements
and those disenfranchised by the new
liberal regimes and of course the middle
classes were claiming with every other
everyone else was reclaim a change in
policy a better economy regaining their
jobs that mix in with those claims there
were claims for different forms of City
making what we see here is social actors
actor in new forms of direct action
politics we see the appearance of what
it was called Assam Leah's very Alice or
neighborhood assemblies we see
man's both to the national government
and to the city government for more
transparency and more accountability
more rights to participate in deciding
the direction that urban development was
taken and what's interesting about this
mobilization although they never reached
the volume that popular mobilization
took these mobilisations continued well
after the stabilization of national
politics marked by the election of
President kercher in 2003 those
mobilized middle-class actors continued
mobilize continue with the protest with
their urban-based Pradas so they demand
a more decentralization to see the
government and their increasingly based
their claims on the local scale on
neighborhood politics so what we see
also among these social actors and
impressive an interest for the
institutions of municipal government in
the city of Buenos Aires mechanisms of
citizen participation in planning
batched budgeting and also
government-sponsored cultural activities
of which there have been many in Buenos
Aires we see also new forms of
collective actions new rep what it's
called with a literature called
repertoire of collection team action and
what we see is an interesting back and
forth between collaborative participate
of collaborative mobilizations a citizen
participation in spaces sponsored by the
state to neighborhood activism street
protests and so on this participation as
I said is it's clearly a middle class
participation not only because of the
sociological characteristics of of the
actors involved largely middle income
professionals largely people with
ownership and housing stability but also
because where they take place most of
the mobilized neighborhoods most of the
mobilizations and the
the organizations that we see in in
these new politics our base have a
territorial base in traditional middle
class areas of the seats and such as for
example couched oh my god minutes left
okay amazing how fast it goes right okay
so um as I said the Communist
redistricting was of these institutions
that this actors focused on and what I
wanted to explain hopefully I have the
time is that this localism was in an odd
neglectful part a reaction to the
directions that city the urban
development had taken during the
previous year or during the 1990s with
stress nationally oriental growth so
what you see here the four first
concerns of mobilized actors the
mobilized actor stated are basically a
reaction to a crisis reactions to them
were social mobility but the bottom
three what you see there are also
reactions to these new forms of
transnational oriental growth and the
resulting social special inequalities
mobilized actors want to have the
coolness to have more control over crime
and insecurity the fear of this multiple
other such as those that appear around
the Ambassador to try to deter
consequences of over development that
they associate with speculative mega
projects that had appear in the 1990s
and that continued being developed in
the 2000s and also to try to manage
processes of gentrification neighborhood
change and residential displacement
caused by the expansion of cultural
entertainment and leisure facilities
catering to the growing mass of foreign
tourists and international visitors
however as I said the communist became a
law and impertinent precedented process
of citizen participation those that were
mobilized achieved many things one of
the remain victorious is that the
Communists map was drawn based upon the
geography of the values so previously
existing geographies of
the service delivery that were drafted
by state actors were discarded and the
communist now represent have the were
drawn based upon the territory of the
city's 46 virus you see some of the
various the largest various were able to
keep their own components for example de
varios palermo became como una 14
cachito became commune essex some of the
smaller values such as those downtown
were grouped together into one component
yet their basic territory was kept
together and only contiguous barriers
were joining the same communi let's see
however this part that I wanted maybe I
don't have much time to talk about the
failures or short comments of this
reform what I should say is that the
community largely exist in paper the
first election of representative has
been postponed until 2011 it hasn't
happened mainly because of delays in
opposition mail from city mayors and I
try to understand why this impetus these
achievements that happen in the first
phase in 2006 couldn't carry it through
and I find three reasons one is that
municipal politics have shifted in
Buenos Aires in 2007 mauricio macri was
changed is not interested in the
centralization he's more interested in
contesting the polit the national
politics of kerchner but also we see a
decay in social mobilization there's
difficulties in coordinating multiple
actors with diverse motivations and this
idea of the barrier as a framework of
collective action also begins showing
some of its weaknesses I try to explain
why unfortunately i created this in a
mac so it's not showing here so and
what's happening is that the values
become clearly a fiction the supposed
homogeneity found in the values and the
yearning for a common social good
particularly around that space becomes
clearly impossible with the ongoing
transnational ization and
differentiation of urban space I've
scaled real estate projects created
their own sense of place combining
vernacular histories with turn national
sensitive there's this myth micro values
of those living in those real estate
projects which in a way translates
suburban logics of gated communities
into urban gated communities in the
fabric of the old city there's more and
more international tourism and
international visitors that vibe with
locals for house in an accommodation and
increasingly unaffordable city and I
have the very last one and so did that
kind of fiction of long-term residency
in a value and identification of the
actor with the territory becomes a
lesson lesson of a reality for more
people I'm going to shut up now and I'm
just going to give you to read the
conclusions so we can proceed if you're
interesting in this you can read my
conclusions if you want you can ask me
questions during the Q&A thank you very
much for your attention
well in addition to the crisis of space
we have a crisis of time and I have
enough comments to go for another to use
up everybody's time and I have enough
questions for all of the panelists that
they will never be able to answer in the
two minutes that each of them has but
let me just give some overall
impressions and make some specific
comments about the presentations I
should actually prefix with the
identifying myself I teach or been
planning at hunter college and I've I am
also an editor of Latin American
perspectives and this is my quick
advertisement we're doing a theme issue
on urban latin america i will have I do
have prospectuses around and they'll be
available to everybody in the back and
invite you to submit in English Spanish
or Portuguese one by one well I think
they're there are three important common
elements in all of the presentations one
and two dealt with in various different
degrees and one is the importance of
understanding the cities and culture and
preservation within the context of
colonialism and the u.s. role in Latin
America this is brought out in the first
presentation patricio Delhi I'll talks
about the the contest over it within the
museum of modern art and honey gomez as
well in the context of Caracas Ingrid
Oliva talks about Puerto Rico and its
identity visa V the United States and
Miguel in the context of neoliberal
urbanization
and economic development the second
theme I think that comes out is the
question of revolution and change in
general and its relationship to national
identities and the third one is what
I'll call to borrow from sharon's ook
eens new book The Naked City the
politics of authenticity who gets to
define what gets preserved where and how
I mean these are fundamental questions
and their political questions and they
relate to the first two categories which
is the colonial heritage and its meaning
and to the question of revolution and
change and what that means symbolically
and in real life let me make just a few
quick comments on each of the
presentations I think on the mural ISM
and moma controversy I think there's
another there was another item that I
would like to have seen in there which
is the conflict between abstract art and
revolutionary art which was very much
intertwined with the rejection of
nevada's murals at Rockefeller Center
and the subsequent promotion by
Rockefeller of apt what what he turned
that abstract art and and I think the
really critical question here is this
question of the universality of art I
would put it in a in a different way
though
that that sort of coincides with some of
the themes touched on in the other
presentations which is the conflict
between diversity and monoculture in art
universality is another form of the
monoculture propounded I mean
universality is a myth it's a myth
propounded in a cultural in cultural
wars that produce monocultures that are
in the image of the most powerful with
honey I Gomez's a discussion of Caracas
I think there's some really important
questions that this brings up and many
that i would like to pose for further
discussion this is really where the
whole question of preservation and
authenticity comes up in the context of
a revolution what should be preserved
and what does the colonial the physical
colonial city mean it does its
preservation mean the preservation of
colonial relations and domination I
think there is and I think this is an
important part of the presentation there
is a tendency to associate symbolism
with the real revolution the Billboard
approach to revolution and and that has
produced some of the some of the changes
that occurred but I thought some of
those changes were quite appropriate and
quite interesting others were laughable
but I'm not sure I'm not sure that I'm
here to judge what kinds of changes need
to occur first place cut
cos is hardly a colonial city anymore it
has had one of the most neglected
colonial infra it was it was the city
that was remade remade in the image of
modernism after the discovery of oil and
and in fact the other question I would
pose is is it is it that much different
than what happened in puerto madero
puerto madero and the neoliberal city
it'd be enclaves in in Buenos I days
were they really any that different than
any much different than the modernist
image of the universal international
architecture that had taken over all of
the major cities in Latin America after
the Second World War and and and before
that as well so I think there's some
really really critical questions here
the other question about Caracas is you
know revolutions are messy they're
disorganized and they they create havoc
the real question though politically is
what about the non symbolic revolution
in Venezuela where is that at and I
think that is a question that can't be
answered at this point as yet as far as
Puerto Rico goes I think I just want to
ask Ingrid is that place that sells ice
cream still there in the Placid upon say
in the park a double-barreled and the
the bomberos is still there yeah I I
would have liked to seen the physical
examples of the preservation that you
were talking about and contrast it 20
one may be the physical maybe the the
visual examples are in all that telling
because maybe part of the unique
approach to preservation in bond say is
that it's not strictly based on physical
renovation and I think that's another
question I want to ask all the panelists
very much focused on the physical part
of preservation but the there seems this
seems to be disjointed from the
discussion of cultural preservation and
I think we architects and planners tend
to fetishize the physical without
sufficiently giving attention to the
political and the cultural and then
finally on buenos I days I have to
confess I am one of the persons who
commit this mistake all the time in the
with regard to New York City when we
talk about New York City we talked about
the city of New York the 8 million
people living in the core and I think
buenos its is one of those other cities
in the world where when people talk
about Buenos its they always talk about
the core as I say I make this mistake
all the time I was talked about but his
presence because of the historic
identity and the power of the core in
the strength of the core but the
majority of population in Buenos Aires
lives outside this city of Buenos Aires
and it would have been nice to have a
discussion about the meaning of the
preservation of the core for those who
live outside in the periphery and with
regard to the question of participation
it would have been nice i'm sorry we
didn't have more time to hear the
the story but the participation of the
middle class this is a big question also
in New York where many of the protests
and much of the community and
neighborhood base place-based organizing
is led by what are called the middle
class but quite frankly I don't know
what that is I'm not sure what the
middle class is anymore because it is
very heterogeneous and it includes a
great diversity of people at the in
different occupations different income
levels and so forth and there's often a
surprise that the middle class is
organizing but I'm not so sure that at I
think I I'm more concerned about the use
of that category because it is so in
precise in trying to make a point or
demonstrate something it if the
categories aren't appropriate it's going
to be difficult to make that make that
point so these are these are my comments
a little scattered but I think overall I
really appreciated the four
presentations that have a good deal of
overlap then I think cover some of the
big questions in a very short period of
time that ran out thanks would you come
and join us for
from Rockefeller of the 50s books one is
one of the first one of these stories is
crossing all these exhibitions is
basically Rockefeller Center and I would
on that which is a very well-known story
i was just like to comment on the one
the one-page letter that Rockefeller
sent to do a beta before the lawyers
took over and basically he stated that
he that they have never intervene on on
his wonderful art that actually he says
the the head of Lenin is wonderfully and
beautifully executed the problem is and
Rockefeller stated that such
representations are it's a matter of
space that Rockefeller Center was a
public space and literally if I remember
correctly it's perfectly fine to have
linen any private space not in the
public space of Rockefeller Center
period and that was that's all he said
so the problem for Rockefeller this
moment and because of other issues that
rose with similar problems in the in the
muralist shows it's the problem for
Rockefeller in which he was actually
pretty young at this time so it's kind
of interesting see his perspective is
not that it was Lennon it was actually
was public space because we see had
absolutely no problem with Orozco's
linen in the in the in the new school so
this very interesting defense of mural
ism that are that it from Paris
particular people from moma let's being
launched from or myself a mamas now this
from homogeneous ending
okay I I would like to thank you your
comments and to respond to them I was
very subtle and delicate and trying to
put good photographs of something that I
dislike very much which is the
imposition of an opinion in a democratic
capital in there are many people that
are that know about preservation that
have never been asked what what what is
it their opinion what's going on in this
huge restoration program in the city so
but because I was a first surprised when
I put up the photograph together of the
before-and-afters that of course you you
have the feeling that restored buildings
look better because they were up before
decay but the thing is that the colonial
core it's it's very small the remaining
buildings are very few Caracas is I
didn't show it in the photographs with
its vast as you said contemporary modern
city made basically on grey light cement
and concrete so the the color of the
city's rather light and a few colonial
and 19th century buildings are you
pleased that heartbeat are being
affected so in terms of of preservation
the the impact is huge because that is
what is left it's not that that you did
you just have like a program and you are
like improving the city is that there is
a direct propaganda as you said also
situation with the manipulation of the
restorations which is for for for me
personally very sad
and of course we will look at the
cultural and political part of the
program but as we have done in in our
country some so much discussions and on
the political side I want it to be three
majors in the visual and historical
presentation of the different cases so
yes they still sell ice cream in central
pons late highly recommended to
everybody go to that square oh yeah two
thumbs up so your comment about working
more on the physical examples of
preservation versus on one good point I
actually was trying to do move away from
that and look at the political Civic
meanings of it which is why i tried to
use the cartoons and the postcards and
there's other ways of addressing the
issue instead of the actual physical a
victory of it but that's good to be in
it as well and yes in ponce a
preservation actually yeah the concept
has moved from preserving colonial
architecture in ponce a to taking care
of cultural heritage which includes
intangible manifestations festivals the
celebration of afro boricua traditions
such as bands sports and so on so it has
moved to encompass a larger
understanding of culture and cultural
signifiers that were rejected before and
it's still a contested process for
example there's a particular
neighborhood barrio San Antone which has
been heralded as their preservation of
Afro boricua urbanism and that actually
a lot of the people interviewed ER they
said this is not a fro at all this is
the result of the overlap of poverty and
inclusion so this change of meanings
what is attached to the built
environment what is intangible and so on
I think has has been addressed it and
it's still contested in motion but it
has and it has moved from being
something that took place in the island
like colonial architecture to something
that defines our identity these are the
terms that they use our as something
that has become personal and collective
at the same time alright well thank you
Tom for giving me the chance to clarify
some aspects of my presentation that
have may have been misunderstood first I
didn't mean to ignore that what I was
talking about with the city of when
Osiris with the capital C it's the
city's institutional city I meant the
three million third of the population
with a population of three million
that's the capital of Argentina and not
the metropolitan area and that's true
most of the people live outside the city
but also most of the people depend on
the resources concentrated in the city
of Buenos Aires metropolitan Buenos
Aires is a very strong core urban region
where a lot of the resources from the
economic to the social cultural
resources of the city are concentrated
in the center those nine million have no
say in how these resources are managed
it is only the three million voters of
the city and the political institutions
that manage them so sometimes we do have
to focus on the city as it happens in
New York so first clarification second
clarification um in my presentation I
think in these slides as well as in my
paper that is when we were red I never
talked about the middle class I always
use the term in the plural case I always
talk about the urban middle classes
because of this heterogeneity this
fracturing that is happening and these
instabilities within this in social in
between the reason why I wanted to focus
on this social in between is because
most of the studies focus perhaps this
is easier to define the poor or the
elite but with that we missed a lot of
the complexities happen in urban
politics the multiple actors the
intervening factors and that's why I
focus so much on this territorial
framework devaglia which i believe is
was
one attempt by this diverse
heterogeneous group of actors to seek a
social common interest perhaps a
place-based class interest if you will
in in an era where class determinations
have become harder to define and more
complex yet there's failures in this and
this in this local isn't this assumed
homogeneity of the local territory and
that's what I wanted to tell you my
conclusions that perhaps i didn't get
about how do can we use what we now know
about transnationalism to articulate a
new sense of place a sense of locality
and neighborhood that somehow is able to
coexist with this transnational
realities that is that does not become
exclusionary and neglectful of the oldy
outside in present in those
neighborhoods questions yes
that's me in terms of how can we relate
then a preservation to issues of
citizenship so I have two questions for
two of the presentations the first one
in grade is making a good effort and
interesting effort to relate this
preservation with alka Nanami with
autonomy then I'm trying to photo enemy
inside and I'm planning so um here again
I find in your presentation and in your
case that we're dealing with this
cultural difference problem so I would
like you to elaborate a little bit on
how is that this preservation issue is
allowing new identities to be whether a
file has you said or be recreated in
terms of autonomy how are they allowing
the opening in its face for cultural
differences to be recreated or
reproduced and in the presentation of
Caracas uh yeah i agree with a moderator
it says that it was representations were
really rich in terms of descriptive
images and historic background but i am
keen to know a little bit in a more
theoretical way how do you again
elaborate these issues of changing
authenticity or preservation and the
notion of revolutionary changing
anything in terms of social processes is
it is opening spaces for being for
contest revolutionary or political
processes going on or how do you see
that
okay Oh take take a few comments okay
sure be back faranak on presentation
about the Caracas to follow up I am not
familiar with urban preservation
literature or discussions but from the
natural environmental conservation and
debates the political ecology literature
and scholarship that is in that field
has been very critical that natural
environmental no conservationists often
think that they are not political but
it's actually very political in a sense
of their commitment to the past and how
they talk a lot about the preservation
for example of parts that have been
based on this position of indigenous
land and then now insistence on
conservation is kind of like continuing
on those dispositions that rather than
so commitment to the past rather than to
a commitment to the future and change
and I'm not sure if that those same
debates that political ecology has been
able to reveal in terms of natural
conservationists the end conservation
that exists in the urban conservation
that yeah I guess that's that's what i
want to thank you yes you had
I have a question for Miguel I did read
your paper and I know that you perhaps
add a little bit less time in your
presentation to address on this
particular area of your paper so bear
with me everybody else in terms of the
argument about the transnational the
emerging trans national identity of
these videos I am sort of still confused
about how the post neoliberal regime
demand for the local control of the
neighborhoods is shaped by the
transnational interactions I think right
now there's a focus and there was a
focus in your presentation on very
localized reactions to what was going on
in the city and I was wondering if you
could perhaps illuminate for us a little
bit on how this post neoliberal call for
neighborhood level control is based on a
conflict that comes from a larger arena
rather than just the city of Buenos iris
as you emphasized in your presentation
thank you
it it it seems to me that one of the
great historical continuities in this in
the shape of the space of Windows I
adays is this constantly frustrated
policy effort to kind of clear out the
center you know whatever the center is
at the moment and get the poor people
and the less white people and someone
out of the center and out into the
margins and it's seem to still be going
on and always frustrated never their
visas you know right near the mucus
enthroned so on and I was I was thinking
two things hearing your presentation one
of them was does any of the changes
you've been talking about either in sort
of mobilizations coming out of the audio
to the vivaz or these ghouls represent
any change in that policy in that effort
to kind of create a sort of a clean you
know well-to-do orderly center and push
the working class and disorder and so on
up to the margins and then also coming
from New York where the gentrification
efforts have been so successful in the
sense that you don't have that kind of
mixing of neighborhoods certainly in
Manhattan it's very very successfully
been pushed out the outer boroughs to
northern Manhattan and there's I part of
my reaction to the sort of heterogeneity
you were talking about and that I've
experienced in Buenos I adays was that's
fantastic I wish we had more of that
around here and I just wonder if there's
another side to that that I'm not
thinking over if you have anything to
say about okay we're gonna we don't have
much time so I one last quick question
talk about this kind of series of
translations as Diego kind of comes into
Phillips pay if it's a kind of Mexico
into the United States so this kind of
mural exterior into the domestic
interior and at this kind of political
engagement into the kind of aesthetic
commodity and I was just wondering if
you could you know maybe read the
content of the murals that you know
Rivera presented in that exhibition is
some kind of response to this
translation like I mean a response not
just to being in the United States but
also to having his work kind of
presented in a museum I don't know if it
was the first time he's worth is kind of
presented in an institutional context
but ok again two minutes maximum for
each president since were behind
schedule wants to start well I would
like to respond to the questions one
thing that of course I I couldn't read
the whole presentation because I am
always too long writing and there were
many things explained about the trans
positions of their monuments of the
statues of the indian goddess Mary
alianza I think I didn't mention that
the statute that broke and the to
columbus statues their stories well one
of the problems are of our country is
that we are we have very few published
studies on urban urbanism and in
architecture so people have the feeling
that the architecture of the aggregate
culture and the environmental culture is
non existing it's like there is nothing
important to to be saved so decisions
are taken very easily and very fast and
the principal credit system that there
is behind our presentation and behind I
think I feel of all the people that live
in Venezuela then
are not with this regime is that who as
there is a lot of money in the country
why there are not new spaces urban
spaces for the the celebration of the
indigenous cultures over the new ideals
political ideals there are no classes
for the revolution they're not no new
squares no new monuments at it this
obelisk we don't know what's going to
happen with that but of course it
shouldn't be placed in the center of the
capital and the main believer square
it's like destroy in it so our concern
is for criticizing an array of decisions
that are very easily taken and there
they just go away with what there is
left and and that's very sad um one
thing that perhaps I didn't clarify in
my presentation this problematic
character that I was talking about is
not that i seed problematical but this
mobilized actors would find this
juxtaposition spre matical and yes the
city of Buenos Aires at least since the
early 20th century has tried to expel
the other from the center and it has
failed because basically that large mass
of metropolitan poverty the real when
his hires a real Argentina that tom was
so concerned about that it's ever
present and coming back to the center
and it goes on the Metropolitan Police
that the mayor of when Sir Richard start
isn't just another attempt to do that to
clear the city of 10 stars from that one
interesting thing about this
neighborhood movements in this movie
like middle classes is that they did not
at least explicitly adhere to that their
local control they did they were not as
exclusionary particularly if you compare
them to suburban municipal decision
movements in the United States the
suburban taxpayers that kind of
exclusionary behavior was not present
among the urban middle class
I studied in a way they try to frame
processes of coexistence and in
particular in terms of the use of urban
public space in the street with the
Metropolitan poor present in their
neighborhoods in the neighborhoods where
they resided try to look for ways of
articulating that kind of living
together I wrote a little bit more about
this in a paper that's coming out in
environment and playing a this year I
can we can talk about it afterwards to
the other question and when the city
begins transnational izing through these
mega projects dispersed throughout its
space it I think that's the
transnational link because these
projects are first financed by
transnational capitals also geared to
international tourists to create a
cosmopolitan statics in the city and yes
their consequences are local and there
perhaps experienced locally by the
mobilized actors and that's why they
frame their issues and grievances in
terms of a neighborhood problem but it's
not a purely neighborhood problem
because it's connected to the circuits
of capital to the circuits of
international tourism to those cultural
circuits of what constitutes a
cosmopolitan static hopefully this
answers the question more and thank you
very much for reading my paper I just
want to add something to what Miguel was
saying it I actually think there is a
good parallel with New York City many of
New York City's Central neighbors are
quite heterogeneous have resisted
displacement and so I always think of
Buenos Aires is one of the city parallel
cities with with New York and that in
that sense the myth of gentrification is
that it's all become homogeneous but
that that's quite a myth
so Marcela concerning your question on
how preservation citizenship autonomy
and new identities are related I think
it's key to read preservation in another
vocabulary beyond the vocabulary of the
buildings and the particular physicality
of what it's left of the built
environment of the past but to move on
to the bigger questions like which tom
worth mentioning which are Lukens
politics of authenticity who and gets to
decide what is to be preserved and to be
forgotten how when and what kind of
resources are given to that and what is
that this course is that a company that
kind of preservation so because it's
fundamental in the way that it shapes
habitus this frameworks of thought that
condition parts of action and those
parts of actions are related on related
to recognition and redistribution of
power of resources of space and so on so
what I'm trying to say is that it is
fundamental to re-read preservation in
this other light and particularly for
example in the case of Khan say the new
identities there is even if preservation
has moved from this basic Hispanic
preservation based view it's still very
exclusionary it is no luck it is not by
luck for example that the Diaspora
elements of Puerto Rico are not still in
the main discourse of preservation
Dominicans for example are now a large
chunk of of the visible other in Puerto
Rico but they are absolutely excluded
from preservation so this is completely
tied to notions of entitlements to
notions of Rights who has to say who
hasn't right to say a waste is we are
remembering the past or four or five
hundred years ago or the past five years
ago what is our past and where is it
leading so I think in
all the way of seeing it it's where I
want to frame my discussion and still a
lot to be done for example this in the
case of immigrants in Puerto Rico big
absence in the case of the themes of the
Nevada murals I mean we have two
instance is one of the murals that he
was brought to new york to perform for
the museum there were a total of eight I
believe six were citing the murals in
Cuernavaca and shopping go in Mexico
City than what he became famous for and
then two or actually murals about New
York sadly these murals have disappeared
nobody knows where they are so we don't
know actually the exact subject matters
of those mirrors in the case of the ones
that where we produce I mean they do not
abandon any of the revolutionary images
I mean they have peasants workers the
cafe is there's a papa is also there so
you know he still maintains you know the
notion of revolutionary narrative and in
the end this is worse play if Johnson
was actually forwarding a narrative of
blank walls when I de travail de and
other people are actually forwarding
narratives on walls in a in a crisis
state it specifically in New York
alright so that's so it's a narrative of
crisis and revolutionary and revolution
okay thank you all very much